we believe that our work will help in
reinvigorating the European single
market that will ultimately lead to
robust economic growth across the whole
continent today we've reached two
general approach approaches on the
ranking of unsecured debt instruments in
insolvency hierarchy and on the
transition arrangements to mitigate the
impact of IFRS 9 on own funds as well as
for certain large exposures in addition
institutions shall have the flexibility
to issue less costly ordinary unsecured
senior debt and despite all the efforts
of our presidency and all the
discussions and workgroups carried out
we did in fact find a balanced
compromise text for both proposals and
we can say that there was a very very
large support shown for this compromise
and however and we have to report that
today's meeting we couldn't get the
unanimity which is required on the tax
proposals on both on both proposals
essentially the presidency we had
reached a deal in a principle to restart
securitizations markets and we also
reached political agreement on the rules
two strengths and funds for venture
capital and social entrepreneurship so
we welcome today's agreement on two
important measures first agreement on
the bank creditor here here which will
allow for larger banks to build robust
buffers of bail aníbal depth today's
agreement sensible signals that Europe
is advancing steadily on completing our
regulatory framework for banks